PERCENTAGE LIFETIME. LA
GETS PASSED GAVRIKOV.
THE FOOT
RACES TO PUCKS IN THE
NEUTRAL ZO FIVE ON FIVE,
THIRD LINE.
MAKES A NICE LITTLE
OFF OF THE
STICK OF
BOARDS.
MARCHAND IS THERE.
GOES
DOUBLE PASS . KES
A GREAT PUNT FAKE BUT
CAN'T NAVIGATED OFF
BY JEREMY
SWAYMAN WHO COMES OUT
OF HIS GLOVE AND GUS
SHOT.
MAY HAVE TO
CHANGE THE LOGO ON
THE  DANFORTH
SCORES ON THE REBOUND.T
HOCKEY
CHINAKHOV.
LOW FROM NYQUIST, ORTH.
THE SHOT BY ANDREW
PEEKE BLOCKED.
CAAND HOLD IT AT
THE SAME TIME.
VORACEK TH
94.6 SAVE PERCENTAGE
AGAINST THE BRUINS TAKE
DEBRUSK  DEBRUSK,
BERGERON,
CHARLIE McAVOY COMES
ALL THE WAY IN,
ATTACKS THE ,
USK WORKING
ON BEAN.
REALLY SOLIDLY TODAY.
AGAIN, FOR COLUMBUS.  T
GAMES.
BERGERON HAS 1 ON EDGE
GOING FURTHER AND
FURTHER AWAY FROM
McAVOY.
YOU WERESCORES
.  THE
MAN ADVANTAGE AND YOU
GET THE FACE-OFF THING
RUSH BUT THE BETTER
PLAY WAS  DOWN THE
WALL.
EMPTY NET TO
THEY GET THE
GOALTENDER PULLED OFF
THE RUSH, THEY THROW
THE PUCK , THAT
FINISHES IT.CLOSER
THAN THE FINAL SCORE
WILL BE.
>> Andy: IT WAS BUT I